[Musique]
des nuages menaçants à l'horizon
annonciateur depuis depuis une semaine
astro peint entre les gouttes alors il
faut profiter de chaque moment de soleil
car le travail est immense sa torpeur
avec ça et des d'antoine il doit
repeindre complètement les 1400 m² de la
façade du château qu'on arrivait donc il
était tout noir ensuite on a fait des
traits de construction avec des à l'aide
d'une ficelle d'un fils après j'ai
commencé à remettre mais mais mais
qu'elle est graphie sur sur les parties
que j'avais besoin qui reste noir
après j'ai mis les couleurs où il
fallait et là on a la moitié à peu près
de cette phase là le turquoise et le
violet ses couleurs fétiches
son style l'illusion d'optique habitué
aux fresques murales cette résidence
d'artistes reste particulière ça reste
un défi parce que les murs plante je
sais déjà que bas que je l'avais déjà
fait plusieurs donc je sais que ça se
passe bien là la difficulté c'est
justement les les balcons comme ça les
espèces de renfoncement qui a partout
sur le château est d'arriver à faire
quand même des lignes droites on a dû
reculer et que ça fonctionne
[Musique]
je me suis justement appuyé du noir de
la couleur noire pour éliminer pas mal
de relief et de deux zones qui pouvait
embêter et j'ai aussi utilisé pas mal de
lignes existantes du château pour fermer
construction dessus à ce qu'on pense
terminer son travail d'ici la fin de la
semaine
il veut représenter la lumière au bout
du tunnel
un message d'espoir pour tous ceux qui
veulent en finir avec la crise du coc
vide